Tereza mayor has today published an
article in the Sunday Express which to
my eyes looks a carbon copy of the
promises she made on this program at the
beginning of the year identifying mental
health care provision as a an area of
concern since January what has she done
well the beginning of the years you know
she made it very clear that one of her
priorities is to put mental health on
the same footing as physical health in
terms of the parity of esteem and the
way in which people who suffer mental
health get treated and we've done a
great deal to try to start implementing
that promise so this week that's last
week
Paul Farmer who's the chief executive of
mind the mental health charity and Lord
Stevenson who's been a mental health
campaigner in the house of laws
published a report that was commissioned
by the prime minister to encourage
businesses and organizations starting
with the NHS and the civil service to
provide much greater awareness support
and commitment to help people with
mental health conditions in the
workplace and when those those
recommendations are implemented and have
had time to bear then we will have you
back on the show and we can discuss them
but literally from the beginning of this
year what improvements have you made to
mental health care provision so we've
made a commitment on the finances we
increased the money spent on mental
health last year by over 500 million
pounds we have a commitment to invest
over a billion pounds over the next four
years we've published the mental health
workforce plan to help deliver
improvements to achieve many of the
targets that we've also added into the
mental health system so we're planning
21,000 additional posts in mental health
over the next four years as well as
setting targets for psychosis for
children being seen in a way that well
psychosis will be the first country in
the world to have set a target for six
weeks of access to talking therapies I
mean it isn't as if the NHS has just
woken up to the idea of a lack of mental
health care provision you know 23
percent of NHS activity goes towards
mental health just 11 percent of the
budget so extra money is fantastic great
all the rest of it but you know it's a
drop in the ocean
next to that which is required well as
I've said we're increasing them funding
going into mental health services by
about 10 percent in real terms over the
course due to rise by not 0.7 percent
next year which actually in real terms
is a current know it's going to go up by
in real terms per capita over this year
so we've pledged that quite clearly in
our manifesto and we're increasing by 8
billion over the next over the course of
the parliament and over the last two
years it's gone up by five percent so
there has been a significant increase in
resources we're obviously just ahead of
the budget and we'll see what will that
will mean for for coming years through
the budget discussions but given tamela
not deny that the government is finally
starting to get to grips with mental
health or at least trying to get to
grips but but to measure to measures
from the Care Quality Commission show
that you know since 2010
you know this government really has
taken its eye off the ball the number of
people who had to travel outside their
own area for mental health care rose
between 2014-15 and 2015-16 by by 40%
the number of detentions under the
Mental Health Act has risen by 1/5 in
two years I mean up till this point
would you concede that you've got it
wrong and mental health
as you know we've had a number of
challenges and priorities to deal with
over the last few years I think that
focus following the mid staffs report in
in 2012 was that we've got some had some
real patient safety issues across our
hospitals and physical health and the
was a priority given to raising staff
levels of nurses in particular on our
wards which have gone up by close to
11,000 since 2010 and mental health was
one of the areas which saw a reduction
during that period in nurses and that's
what we're now trying to put right it
does take time it takes time to train
people to undertake these very
challenging roles and that's why we're
committing both the resource and the
workforce plan to recruit more
therapists more doctors more nurses into
the mental health community they speak
more generally about the NHS as a whole
for a second I mean you raise the matter
of staffing there I mean it appears that
you've got some very real problems it's
great that you are looking to secure
people for these positions but you don't
appear to be finding them your NHS
England in March thirty thousand six
hundreds full-time equivalent positions
advertised that's up from twenty four
twenty six thousand at just the year
before I mean the problems in terms of
staffing within nail service are not
getting better on your own metrics
they're getting wise well no I think at
what I point you to is the requirements
for more staffing to make sure that our
hospital wards are safe and that's what
one of the reasons why last month the
secretary of state made it very clear
that he wants to increase the number of
nurses in training for the NHS of the
future by a record amount by twenty five
percent starting next year so there will
be more than 5,000 additional training
places for nurses on top of the
additional 25% increase in doctor
training posts which were announced the
year before so we absolutely recognize
we need more staff in our hospitals in
primary care helping cope with the
growing demand that we have from an
aging population it does strike
sometimes that whenever we talk about
that the health service don't no matter
the political view of the individual
that we talk to you know it's always
about what we're going to do going
forward not about what has happened
doctor the
point I mean can we just well for a
second on targets within the NHS I mean
that there are no fields on mass across
the service you know in 2012-13 86
percent of time related targets were hit
that fell to not percent in 2016-17 we
are under considerable pressure in the
NHS at the moment because of growing
demand as a result of the aging
population the fact that we're living
longer with more complex conditioners
nobody's trying to deny that or hide
that what we have to do is to ensure
that we've got more people coming into
the system to provide the care that's so
urgently needed and look at the way in
which we provide care one of the
comments that the chief medical officer
furniture's England sabri secured was
talking about today was to ensure that
we have one of the safest systems in the
world that's the ambition of the
secretary of state that's one of the
reasons why we've set up the healthcare
safety investigations branch in order to
provide greater ability for the health
service across the country to react when
things go wrong and learn from mistakes
so there's a combination of providing
more financial resource more human
resource and doing things better and
more safely in order to try and get
better outcomes for patients that is the
objective mr tong i wonder if we might
move on to allegations of abuse in and
around the Palace of Westminster and
we're told via The Sunday Times that the
Prime Minister is receiving of their our
weekly briefing on the end discretions
of her backbenchers should that
information be made public
I think that's a report which I don't
recognize I mean what the Prime Minister
has done today is to ask the Cabinet
Office to investigate whether or not
allegations that have been made about a
colleague are in breach the ministerial
office worked for a length of time mr.
Dunn you're not telling me that the
whips don't have information on their
back benches that they then use to get
them to vote in a particular way you're
you're right I wasn't the Whip's office
and when I was in the Whip's office it
was very clear that anything in the
Whip's office stays in the Whip's office
there are allegations made of
opportunities from across parties all
that their allegations made about
colleagues of all kinds of things which
come to the attention of the whip some
of them are true some of them are and
they're not be true and we're and this
should be the arbiter of whether or not
it's I mean there are allegations being
made to the Whip's office that they sit
on and they arbitrate upon what I was
going on to say is that if there are any
allegations of inappropriate behavior or
in or illegal behavior clearly they get
acted upon what the Prime Minister's
also done today is to write to speaker
Burke Oh to ask him to set up a
cross-party a parliamentary procedure to
enable members of staff who feel that
they've been harassed or bullied to have
a place to go which is independent of
their employer and I think that's
entirely appropriate and we need to get
on and put that in place the end of our
time and you know but you appear to be
making the same point that Owen
Patterson made a few moments ago which
is that there is a difference between
improper behavior and illegal behavior
so I just want to ask you a few kind of
yes/no questions you know I mean would
you ever send explicit sexual texts to
someone who'd applied for a job in your
office
do you know what I think that's some
completely inappropriate question of
course the answer is that no but I don't
think we should be going down it's
completely inappropriate behavior I
think mr. Knapp is admitting to it it is
can we do it with your sentiment Europe
would you ever send your parliamentary
staff to go and buy sex toys for you
this is not somewhere where I'm prepared
to get into these conversations of
course I don't do that have not never
done that kind of activity and I don't
condone it but I don't think that you
that it's appropriate to have sort of
trial by media trying to to pin
allegations until they're proven it's by
the media that the latter allegation has
been admitted look weird in the
ministerial code is that kind of
behavior covered well if it's not
covered in the code the code needs to be
revised I accept that and I just want to
pick up and comments made by Michael
Gove yesterday because in terms of the
egregious in the spectrum those were
pretty much at the far end I mean his
joke sometimes I think that coming into
the studio with you John Humphrys is a
bit like going into Harvey Weinstein's
bedroom you just pray that you emerge
with your dignity intact the Environment
Secretary there saying that women who
have been abused have had suffered
through no fault of their own you know
yeah a degradation in their own dignity
I don't think that it's appropriate to
make light of these kinds of sexual
harassment claims regarding
public figures I think that's I agree
it's it I'm not appropriate the problem
is the mister dunne is that when these
things happen
full apology is issued we simply move on
and and we're supposed to forget about
it but it is illustrative isn't it that
you had not just the environment
secretary but the former leader of the
Labour Party Lord kenick
in a weighing in as well you know making
jokes at a time when the spotlight is on
everyone in public life around
allegations of impropriety
I think the spotlight in this country
has been on people in public life since
the exposures about Jimmy Savile took
place and I think all organizations need
to look at themselves and how they
conduct themselves when they're speaking
to the public and wherever it happens to
be whether it's in politics or or mr.
Dunnigan I'm so sorry but they need to
leave it there